this house i bought it about 30 years
ago for very little money and there was
absolutely nothing there was ceiling
were falling down there was no
electricity no priming nobody was living
here for 12 years you had good visions
so i did but the staircase was in here
that was that so the building was
originally from the 30s
1920s yeah
and it's got those incredible ceilings
thank you you did a great job and here
we're coming to the living room so we
can go around this is fast you spend a
lot of time in this room yes yes because
the television is very peaceful oh this
is that this is sort of where we can
expect ivana to be hanging out with a
certain somebody take a look right over
there okay
it's my boyfriend rosano hi i'm asana
how are you how are you hi hello let me
ask what's the best thing about this
woman
this tough question is there is a lot of
things good about this woman
and first thing that comes to mind my
personality the energy brilliant
definitely brilliant moment well that's
a good answer i knew i liked you so this
is absolutely gorgeous did you use a
decorator or are you your own deck i
really was doing everything myself gosh
you are but you know many talents all of
my homes are different trying to count
how many homes are there ivana
well i have a home here in new york i
have a house in palm beach i have a
pirate you know house in in london
i have a three of them in santro pay one
next to the other one they are old
fishermen houses
very very cute and then i have three in
check
in czech and boat and in australia
so
real estate is good real estate is good
it's better than i prefer i have my
money straight that's right i prefer you
know for 2.8 per cent you definitely in
real estate you know your money
appreciates so is this where the kids
were raised
in this house in the house yeah first
international tower of course right and
then then uh then in this house and they
have this is a seven story high
and you have some pictures of the kids
in here oh so great
it's a graduation of ivanka this is her
look at her there she's so beautiful and
there's the whole family and i just want
to point out one other thing this is all
your cosmetics this is a part of it
which is which i'm doing you know this
is like my i've got my jewelry i have
all my spiders because i've sold
millions of dollars over the years and
if i just don't have an another color
give me another color i can make it in
are you telling me that these spiders
might have paid for one of these many
houses
close very close and then of course all
kind of cosmetics and my fragrances and
all that stuff this is my new line this
is pink champagne you know this is all
the body cream but it's so gorgeous
you know there are great lines it's a
it's a this one elegance it's a
wonderful fragrance
yeah okay
yeah and so you know i have a lot of
things so this is the dining room
kitchens and then we go up another
connection then i have another
three froze above and gymnasium wow well
thank you for letting us into your world
what a pleasure i really enjoyed meeting
you thank you nothing but success thanks
i know you don't need that
thank you bye